Buffer overflows are also the topic of one of my most favorite bug story
which was reported by Isenstadt in '97.
He once had a system that would work only under very specific circumstances,
sometimes it would, sometimes it wouldn't.
The crucial parts of memory in this story are two variables,
one is the day of the week and the other one is a variable which we will simply call ok.
Ok can take a value which is either yes or no.
By default in this story, ok would be set to no.
However, ok has to be set to yes in order to work.
Now, the day of the week in this eight character array would be something say like Monday,
and on Monday, the program would not work.
It also would not work on Sunday.
It wouldn't work on Tuesdays either but there would be one day of the week
and only on this day of the week where the program would work just fine.
What is this day over to you.